what if after you die party you goes to  heaven  party you stays here just until things  turn out windgap there was a murder  there another ones missing now get me a  story that my goodness I didn't expect  you the house is not up to par for  visitors I'm just in town on business  kamil liquid gee I'm glad you're home  what calm person doesn't hurt a child  don't help anything  Rylan folks up you got two mutilated  girls on your hands someone else is  doing a Ryland when you're here you're  my daughter everything you do comes back  on me  I think I come back to cause any problem  I can tell you hate this place let me  someone in this towns hiding something  moment says I need to be careful around  me  are you dangerous  you